the price Rises have hit hard
some families cannot afford to feed
their babies safely so they're watering
down bottles switching to cow's milk too
early stealing from shops or buying
second-hand tubs online
Kerry's boy Finley is still bottle fed
she's so Furious about what's happening
to families that she's petitioning the
government for change you feel
uncomfortable even walking down the baby
aisle and looking at the baby milk
because the staff instantly think oh
they're going to Nick that it's like
you're treated as a criminal
just because you want to go and buy baby
milk
help like lower the costs or provide
vouchers for those that work hard for a
living
all of the manufacturers say their
production costs have risen sharply we
went to the only formula milk factory in
Britain kendamill based in Cumbria while
they've raised their prices they
acknowledge their industry needs to do
more for families it's been toughest on
parents it's devastating to see but it
is the result of consistent cost price
inflation led by the multinational
conglomerates that control this Market
how much responsibility should the
industry as a whole take for the
positions that British families are
finding themselves in at the moment we
can't ignore the macro economic shocks
that we've had where we would like more
transparency is about the enormous price
discrepancies between very similar baby
formulas on the market do you believe
them the multinationals when they say
that they are doing absolutely
everything they can on behalf of
families
to keep those costs to a minimum I mean
it's
I don't think that they are pricing
those products as cheap as they could
price them for families
Danon who make aptamil and Cowan gate so
they are freezing the cost of bigger
value packs Nestle who made the SMA
Brands say they're open to discussing
with government what more they can do
the MP charged with investigating infant
feeding is horrified by what's happening
and is demanding a Government Review I
mean the net effect is a children
growing up I'm with you know
developmental issues because they
haven't had the proper nutrition that
they've needed as babies and that's
really quick I think that's the kind of
thing that you see in countries where
there has been you know famine or
malnutrition or war that should not be
happening in the United Kingdom in 2023.
I think it's important to see if the
government could do something around a
ceiling on the coast of infant formula
is a price cap realistic in what is a
commercial Market
well the government allowed this to be a
commercial market and there are times in
the past where the government have set
limits on on the prices of things
there's no reason why one should cost 10
pounds and one should cost 15 pounds the
UK government continues to say that it
is helping with the cost of living but
because feeding never stops parents who
are in this struggle
can't afford to wait for something to
change
Tom Parmenter Sky News